mitten im industriegebiet ist er zu
hause
der imam von w in der moschee hat
beckham allem sein büro von hier aus
lädt er fünfmal am tag zum gebet und
betreut die islamische gemeinschaft
es ist das gut zu hören es ist
freitagmittag das wichtigste gebiet der
woche das haus ist voll
vor allem albaner und türken unter den
muslimen herrscht verunsicherung nach
den anschlägen von paris und bei den
schlagzeilen zum islamischen staat steht
es schlecht um ihr image
auch in wien mit der radikalisierung von
gewissen gruppen muslimische gruppen die
ersten die davon schaden kriegen die
sind die muslime selbst
sie sehen auch die senden nachrichten
sowie die anderen sie merken diese
jugend die zu einer s gruppe sich
anschließen
das macht ihnen auch angst vor allem
jetzt die ältere leute denn sie wissen
es nicht ob basierend eines tages ihre
söhne werden oder oder wer auch immer
alimi predigt verständigen er will nicht
dass der koran für politische zwecke
missbraucht wird zur radikalismus sagt
er an diesem tag allerdings nichts
es ist die gratwanderung eines
geistlichen der alles für die
integration seiner glaubensbrüder tut
und sich doch immer rechtfertigen muss
was im namen seiner religion geschieht
wie zum beispiel steinigungen die
gewisse muslimische länder mit dem koran
legitimieren
dann sollte er mir was nur zeigen steht
nicht drin
im koran nicht und wie sieht es dann mit
polygonen zb mit polygamie eigentlich
gemäß dem koran polygamie ist erlaubt
beziehungsweise erlaubt aber nicht
empfohlen
und er der imam würde er es erlauben
überhaupt nicht also wenn schon dann
spürte
denn dann wäre der fall schon bei mir
also ich bin nur mit einer frau frey hat
hat und zwar glücklich verheiratet und
deswegen überhaupt nicht alimi auf dem
weg zum oberstufenschulhaus o2 hier
stammen viele der schüler aus dem balkan
die meisten sind muss liegen diesen
bringt alimi die grundlagen ihrer
religion bei wenn die muslime beten
wollen sie wählen sich eine richtung
weiß jemand von euch vielleicht zufällig
in welche richtung beten wir man ja nach
mekka richtung mekka wo ist mekka alina
so die gebetsrichtung ist auch für junge
muslime nicht einfach zu finden
sonnenaufgang plus 30 grad nachricht
wenn wir sonnenaufgang ihr hätten dann
während 30 grad nach rechts
neben einem gebets kompass den man beim
beten auf den teppich legen kann hilft
im digitalen zeitalter auch eine ab um
mekka zu finden
alles nützliche tipps doch wie erklärt
er den kindern die anschläge
die im namen ihrer religion stattfinden
wie die von paris
nachdem wir verschiedene bildern gesehen
haben verschiedene zeitungsartikeln
gesehen haben zum teil auch youtube
geschichten da gesehen haben dann haben
wir punkt nummer eins miteinander
diskutiert ist dass eine islamische tat
kann dass ein muslim machen und wir sind
alle muslime also wenn das ein
islamisches tat ist dann sind wir auch
weil er muslime dann wärst du auch in
der lage sein was zu tun
nein mich nicht ja warum denn nein ich
nicht wo ist dann das ende dieser
diskrepanz das möchte ich den
jugendlichen beibringen dass sie es
einmal so diese differenziert die sache
anschauen
am schwierigsten für den imam von will
war aber der kampf für eine neue moschee
nach acht jahren wird sie jetzt auf
einer kleinen parzelle in der nähe der
autobahn gebaut eine moschee ein thema
und das haben wir jetzt gefunden und war
der mann ein verstand so hat uns
verkauft aber normal
wir hatten auch zum teil große
reaktionen können nachbarn eine moschee
in der frauen und männer gleichzeitig
bieten können
damit geht für den imam ein traum in
erfüllung auch wenn ein minarett nur in
der vorstellung existieren kann
aber wenn wir dann eine moschee uns
vorstellen oder ein kind so vielleicht
mal ein blatt geben und dann ein
kugelschreiber zeichne doch eine moschee
dann ist klar was die zeit
ein imam der für seine religion kämpft
im wissen dass es in jeder gesellschaft
kompromisse braucht damit alle
nebeneinander leben können